with halo 5 only a week and a bit away
from being in your xbox one 343
industries have released a bunch of new
info about its multiplayer mode 3 4 3
will be actively monitoring player
behavior which could lead to fans said
behavior includes quitting matches
betrayals or begin killing idling
intentional suicides and excessive
disconnect the plan is to temporarily
ban those who repeatedly engage in these
actions and the duration of each band
will depend on the offense and the
number of previous infractions also
announced is that halo 5 will have
seasonal challenges over your playlist
that resets month sees will challenge
players to have the highest competitive
still ranking possible and will award
special cosmetic items to top players
when you start halo 5 multiplayer the
game will call for you to play 10
matches before being placed into one of
seven competitors still rankle levels
these ranks are bronze gold platinum
diamond honest and champion in ascending
order after you're given a starting rank
you can only improve it by winning more
matches it won't factor in your
individual performance there are six
years to each reg fee to climb up also
from by winning or losing although
through Porphyrius said you will never
drop an entire rank from losing the two
highest ranks works differently however
the 343 explain don't you reach onyx you
will be shown your raw CSR score winning
no longer increases your tier it instead
increases your fear far this allows you
to compare yourself with greater
precision to other players within the
Onyx rank if you establish yourself as
one of the top 200 players in a playlist
you will earn the highly coveted rank of
Champions and to be showing your place
within the top 200 it's been revealed
that the commendations from Halo Reach
are returning although this time they
will have it fine
yes achieving these will reward you with
XP req packs or emblems depending on how
many you unlock 343 is said they plan to
add more commendations in future after
assessing the reception to the current
one as for matchmaking through botha is
that the algorithm will seek to find
combatants at your CSR level or close to
it they also noted that while you will
never join and a real match in progress
also matters do support joining matches
that have already started as you'd
expect medals are also returning in war
zone every metal you earn will increase
your level which in turn left you unlock
a better req you can check out the full
lineup of metals in our story on site
let me know down in that comment section
what you think of halo 5 so far and if
you're keen to get into the multiplayer
for all the latest in gaming news be
sure to stay tuned to games but